king j does your mind ever feel drained
or not wanting to do something what are
some ways to flip that yeah so I think
for me to answer that question my mom
does feel drained at certain times and
when I stop and think about it it
usually comes down to it like the last
thing I have got here which like is
probably last because it's so
foundational you know all the other
things are supported by this is health
right so like for me personally when my
mind Audrina Rowe stop to think about it
it's because I didn't get as much sleep
as I needed to you this week or I
haven't eaten junk food you know or I
didn't go out with my buddies for couple
drinks the night before you know I mean
it's so like there's always going to be
this physical component to how your mind
functions right so making sure that
you're taking good care of yourself and
sleeping and working at the right hours
so like if you're a night owl that's
great um but like if you're not a night
out then working at the I towers aren't
going to help you if they're not going
to help your mind station or that's for
finding the right time work um and being
okay with like this is something as a
writer this is something I've struggled
with you know it's being okay with like
writers block or creativity block you
know like just don't get frustrated with
it you know like if you sit down to
write a blog post or do something
creative beretta script for a video or
shoot something whatever your business
is you know like if you're setting
sitting down with the you schedule your
time you did all the tips that were
talking about today you did it all
perfectly the hour it comes up you sit
down to do the task and you just don't
have the mental creativity and capacity
to do it being okay and don't get
frustrated and just go for a walk get
some fresh air you know due to take a
break do something you love and be a
human being you know because we're human
beings and at the end of the day we're
going to have those moments where our
minds just what we want them to be um
but it's not forever and it's not all
so just accept when it happens if it's
health related because you're not
getting enough sleep try to work on that
you try to fix that kind of thing um if
it's because you had too much or too
little coffee you know adjust your
coffee intake you know so think about
the reasons why but at the end of the
day just be okay was shut it off yeah i
got mine right here just be okay
whenever we get a nice block or spending
time to family are doing like something
that's gonna make you feel really good
and don't get frustrated yeah I agree
and I think a lot of entrepreneurs are
not the healthiest people because we are
running ourselves you know we're
stressed out we've got a lot of things
that I play we're working crazy hours
and so taking care of yourself is super
important the curveball would kind of
throw out here for this question is uh
maybe you shouldn't be doing those tasks
you know one of the things I i see that
is if I'm doing something that I don't
like for too long you can only force
yourself to do something you don't enjoy
doing for a certain amount of time and
at some point you have to ask yourself
like should I even be doing this or not
and there might be something health
reason there might be something
something you just got to get through
but if it's happening for too many days
in a row maybe you need to examine
whether you should be doing this TAS or
not in the first place um that may not
be the answer lady for king j but that's
just kind of an honest opinion you know
for me I love helping entrepreneurs I
can help entrepreneurs all day long I
could like not go to the bathroom I
could miss meals and then realize like I
haven't eaten all day because I'm
sitting here talking out to like I just
I love it it's my passion I get excited
by it I'm talking faster and with more
energy now because I'm thinking about it
ah and so you know i would try to
encourage everybody listening to find
what makes you come alive and try to do
more of that and if you're being drained
by things that that are sucking life
from you maybe you shouldn't be doing
those things anymore and you can only
force yourself for so long to do those
kinds of things